hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and today we will
be talking about the most recent
developments in the seven deadly sins
story including the ongoing showdown
between the demon king on the one side
and Elizabeth and Mellie Otis on the
other the latest chapter revealed some
fascinating things about the potential
for combining demon and Goddess powers
to create incredibly effective combo
attacks and we learned more about the
specific limitations that meliodas is
forced to accept in his battle against
the demon king limitations that the
demon king is planning to exploit to the
fullest by the way I want to give a
quick shout out to all of you down in
the comments over seven deadly sins
videos who have been thanking us for
regularly covering this series I know
that there aren't that many youtubers
talking about the seven deadly sins
especially not bigger youtubers but we
do this because we love the series and
because we appreciate all of your
ongoing support thanks again and let me
know down in the comments if you're
happy with the content we've been
putting out you know I always love
hearing from you if you enjoy the seven
deadly sins content on this channel and
you want to see more you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
and of course this video is discussing
the latest developments in the story so
manga spoilers will be included if
you're not caught up proceed with
caution you have been warned chapter 318
starts off with demon king zelgius and
Mellie Otis duking it out pretty
intensely atop the magic lake malleolus
clearly has the upper hand and even
special spells that the demon king is
using such as the prison gate saber are
unable to stop Mellie Otis in fact
Mellie Otis is effectively using his
sacred treasure the demon sword lost
vein to repulse the demon Kings attack
with the help of full counter at this
point we also see Elizabeth using her
goddess powers to help tag-team the
demon king along with Mellie Otis
together Elizabeth the meliodas create a
very interesting combo move called God
Eater that seems to be extremely
powerful and it looks like it had a
significant effect on the demon king
personally I am fascinated by this idea
of combining goddess and demon powers
these two clans have been at war for
thousands of years
and historically it would have been
extremely rare to see a goddess and a
demon fighting together and that is
exactly why I'm so interested in seeing
malleolus and Elizabeth on the same side
and combining each other's strengths and
compensating for each other's weaknesses
in fact I am so interested in this topic
that I made a whole video called what if
Millie Otis and Elizabeth had a baby and
in that video of my friend Knox taco and
I speculated about what kind of powers
the son of Elizabeth and Ally Otis might
have and how the demon and Goddess
powers could potentially combine inside
this one person if that's something
you're interested in and feel free to
check out that full video I will link it
in a description and at the end of this
video at this point it has become clear
that malleolus has the upper hand over
the demon king inside was Elvis's body
so meliodas decides to start talking a
bit of smack to the demon king he says
that it is now apparent that the demon
king cannot use the ability called the
ruler effectively perhaps because he is
not used to his new vessel yet or
because he is not compatible with it in
case you need a reminder the ruler is an
ability that allows the demon king to
turn the effects of all attacks against
him around so that instead of dealing
damage to him
they actually make him stronger back in
purgatory bond learned to counter this
move by sending his own energy to the
demon king instead of trying to take his
and because of the rulers effect this
ended up hurting the demon king instead
of helping him
however bond is not here right now he is
not present for this battle so the fact
that the demon king still hasn't
activated the ruler seems to suggest to
meliodas that the demon king is still
incapable of using it effectively inside
his new vessel Mele Otis goes on to say
that the demon king in his current state
has no hope of defeating him in
Elizabeth and that he should just return
to purgatory
however the demon king can feel that
beyond his confident facade meliodas is
actually very impatient Mele Otis knows
that the longer he stays in the mortal
plane the more this world will suffer
from natural disasters and calamities
and he wants to defeat the demon king as
soon as possible so that he can go to
the demon realm and spared the mortal
realm from further destruction malleolus
is also clearly holding back against the
demon king because he doesn't want to
kill
eldress in the process meliodas even
tries to contact zelgius directly to get
through to him on the inside and
Elizabeth notes that just like last time
when the demon king possessed meliodas
it is likely that zelgius will need to
also fight from the inside in order to
be able to drive out the demon king it
won't be enough to just physically
defeat the demon king on the outside the
demon king notices that malleolus is
holding back that his punches and
slashes are not nearly as powerful as
they could be we know of course that
this is because malleolus doesn't want
to hurt soldiers and the demon king
knows that the fact that malleolus is
holding back despite having power that
is equal to the demon king peruse that
meliodas is a fool the demon king is
clearly still hoping to win the father
of the Year award with his flawless
parenting
I mean mocking your one son and calling
him a fool for not wanting to kill your
other son whom you just happen to be
currently possessing against his will
those are some epic game or fatherhood
skills right there now I talked about
this in previous videos but just like
when the demon king possessed meliodas
this fight will be a multi-faceted
battle not a simple one Mele Otis is
clearly limited by the fact that he
doesn't want to kill zelgius so he is
forced to hold back and meliodas is also
limited by the fact that he has to rush
otherwise his continued presence in the
mortal realm will keep causing more and
more damage on the other hand the demon
king has no moral limitations whatsoever
like zero he doesn't care what happens
to the body of zeldron and he doesn't
care about what happens to the mortal
plane so he can keep exploiting these
weaknesses and stall for time meliodas
is in a very difficult situation because
he can't physically kill the demon king
but if he doesn't get him out of Zelda's
body then the demon king will start
destroying all of Britannia as soon as
meliodas decides to leave the mortal
realm I expected in the coming chapters
we will see some scenes of zelgius on
the inside and we'll get a glimpse of
what he has been up to
does celtris actually believe that
Mellie Otis betrayed him and killed
gelda or does he see through his
father's trickery and he is ultimately
going to actively resist his father
personally I think zelgius is smart
enough to see through his father's
trickery but the demon king is
definitely playing on Zelda's innermost
emotions by using gelda so we will have
to wait
and see I am very curious to find out
what will happen next in this fight and
definitely let me know what you guys
think down in the comments what else
will happen in the fight can the demon
king somehow be purged from zelgius body
or do they have to just outright defeat
him both on the inside and on the
outside will the real gelda somehow
become involved and if so what role will
she play let me know down below one
important thing that really struck me
about this chapter was the teamwork
between Melly Otis and Elizabeth and how
they were able to blend demon and
goddess powers in order to form
incredibly unique and effective attacks
using opposite forms of magic
these attacks definitely seem to be
effective against the demon king and I
wonder whether this teamwork could be
foreshadowing about what's to come in
the future as you know if you've been
following this channel I've been saying
for a long time that a great ending for
the seven deadly sins would be if Mele
Otis and Elizabeth replaced the demon
king and the supreme deity as the rulers
of their respective clans we know that
the demons and goddesses have been
engaged in a pointless war for thousands
of years and knowing how stubborn and
ruthless the demon king and the supreme
deity are the only way to truly bring
this war to an end is for someone else
to replace the demon king and the
supreme deity as the rulers of the demon
and goddess clans melioidosis power is
already at the level of the demon king
and the fact that Elizabeth Emily odors
are in love makes them the perfect
candidates for the next rulers of their
respective clans
by being together meliodas and Elizabeth
will be a great example to the other
members of their clans that demons and
goddesses don't need to hate each other
and that they can live together in
harmony
having Mellie Otis the son of the demon
king and Elizabeth the daughter of the
supreme deity replaced their parents as
the rulers of their clans and bring an
end to the holy wars once and for all
would be a very satisfying ending to the
series although no ending would be
completely satisfying since I'm sure
that most of us fans don't want it to
end at all let me know down in the
comments if you agree with me that
elizabeth emilio de is replacing their
parents as rulers of their clans and
bringing an end to the holy wars would
be a good ending if you're interested in
this idea of demon goddess powers
combining feel free to
check out my video about malleolus and
Elizabeth having a baby link in the
description and at the end of this video
I also recently made a video called what
if s Kannur and Merlyn had a baby so if
you're interested in how radically
different types of powers could
potentially combine into seven deadly
sins universe you can check that video
out as well if you enjoy the seven
deadly sins content on this channel and
you want to see more please leave a like
to let me know and if you're new to
anime abroad don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell you can
check us out on Twitter and Instagram at
anime out pro-roh the latest seven
deadly sins news and updates a huge
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for supporting our work I want
to give a special thank you to our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson and Kings Alger's and another
huge thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ace
Ingrid ah Maddy Mack and makoto-kun
and at the very pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness the tier
reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to Regan Harrison a disciple
of Lords we go himself if you guys feel
that our content provides value for you
and you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
up for patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]